foreign
so this comes out of the news but George
it's not just a news story
it's actually a pervasive problem
and uh the story in the news right now
in fact it's one of the hottest stories
right now it comes from the political
world
this guy uh named George Santos have you
heard of this guy oh yeah
George is out there you don't keep all
the Georges well so he's a newly elected
congressman from New York if you don't
know what I'm talking about and he's
taken a lot of heat from the media
rightfully so because it's come out and
almost it feels like every day the dude
has just lied and lied and lied and lied
to cover up those lies about his resume
his background so he just lied to
everybody
and boy you know pressure on this guy to
resign
and it's a little bit ironic that people
are now shocked that a politician lied
that's the first time in history a
politician has lied yeah so this is big
news so everybody's trying to grasp that
deal
um and and and then but you know what
there's a deeper thing here and there's
a Temptation for all of us to do
what George Santos has done I'm going to
break that down in a second but I wanted
George you pulled up give us a if you
would just a couple of the Fantastical
lies that this uh this Congressman has
laid out for everybody lied about where
he went to school lied about where he
worked lied about owning a number of
rental properties lied about being
robbed of his rent money lied about his
criminal status in Brazil lied to donors
lied about his athletic accomplishments
lied about the timing of his mother's
death lied about his campaign finances
and this one might be them the funniest
one he lied about being Jewish and then
he came back and said no no no no I said
I was Jewish which is which is even
worse than the LIE it has borderline
comedic yeah oh my gosh yeah I mean so
this is a guy this is pathological
though that's the one right no these are
pathological liar now why don't we bring
this up
in the work context for a moment for
those of you who feel a sense of doubt
maybe you are dealing with imposter
syndrome and we took a call from a young
man earlier this hour trying to get a
job and when we face doubt George
it it tempts us to be deceitful because
we feel like if I'm not good enough
uh I I've gotta make up a story that
makes me good enough that's the slippery
slope and that's what he did well he
took fake it until you make it to a very
dangerous level here man I mean it's
unbelievable so doubt leads to deceit
when we don't manage our doubt I don't
think I'm good enough I don't think I'll
get the job I don't think they'll like
me I don't think she'll marry me I mean
this thing spirals out of control and
it's all deceit lying like this and and
this is unbelievable folks listen to
this data this is this is right here in
my hand CNBC article 55
of Americans admit to lying on their
resume at least once
55 George this is according to a recent
survey from standout CV and now it gets
worse by the way before I tell you this
data if anybody out there wants to
really know
what we the people are really like you
want to know what the people of the
world are really like you want to know
the true Human Condition go look at
Google searches
that's the ultimate indicator of who we
are as humans
case in point
the number of Google searches about how
to fake a resume
is up the search is for how to fake a
resume is up 48 George
uh so what are people lying about here
real quick the top eight reasons or what
they are lying about on their resume
55 of people lie about their previous
work experience well that's smart
because we know no one's going to check
your references
I got anxiety thinking about this George
how do you keep up with the audacity
that you could even pull this off is
impressive here's another one this is my
personal favorite because of the
humility excuse me uh the opportunity to
humiliate yourself
43 people uh admit to lying about their
skills
oh yeah I can operate heavy machinery or
even worse we'll see you on Monday
morning Ken you've done this one I know
Excel
it's a dangerous one yeah but no heavy
machinery what are you doing man that
one could be life literally a
life-altering uh 41 lie about their
college degree 39 lie about personal
details such as age location or name
uh 39 lie about high school hey can I
set everybody free who's tempted to lie
about high school nobody cares what you
did in high school no one not even your
mom or dad because they've forgotten
uh 33 lie about salary
33 lie about Job specific software or
equipment skills and then finally 21 and
this is so moronic I don't even know how
to process it
21 of people lie on their resume about
their employer references
so I guess they're making that up hey
George will you do me a solid I'm
putting you down as a reference so I
give him Ken's number and I go yeah he
was my previous manager give him a call
he'd be happy to talk to you and I slip
you a 20 Bill and say hey Ken if they
call make me look good yeah I I feel
like I need a shower that's how dirty I
feel right now so the solution here
again obviously is to have integrity
which if I'm hiring someone I want to
hire someone with Integrity how do we
get over this hump yeah so back to the
the reason I always like to try to give
you a deep Source behind why we do what
we do and I think doubt is what leads us
to deceit so then if we we need to
manage doubt better what do we do
so if a doubt the way I Define doubt
George is that I don't believe that
Something Good Can Happen
that's doubt I just don't believe that
something good this thing that I long
for this thing that I want to do it
can't happen I doubt that it can happen
for a variety of reasons and so what you
have to do there is you got to go number
one I can't shortcut this doubt I I
can't take my doubt in myself and then
try to shortcut it by lying to everybody
else no I've got to step into me and go
what is the voice of Doubt telling me
I'm too old is that true
I'm a stay-at-home mom I've got nothing
to offer if I enter the workforce is
that true is there any evidence that
that the doubt is telling you the truth
because if doubt is telling you the
truth it's protecting you give you a
silly example
George if there's a basketball 10-foot
basketball goal in the lobby
and I tell all these fine people
watching hey I can dunk have you ever
seen me dunk before watch this I'm gonna
dunk and moments before I go to dunk the
ball I have some serious doubt because I
haven't stretched and let's be honest
I've never dunked a basketball and
Doubt's going I don't know if you can do
this Doubt's protecting me from certain
humiliation silly example but you get
the point I'd lower the hoop for you Ken
just for the record thank you but even
then it'd be a question mark all right
but if doubt is saying I can't ever
start a business I can't pay off debt I
can't get through the baby steps I can't
earn enough money to
that's holding you back that's the idea
so instead of lying and trying to
shortcut which is what people do here to
get the job you got to go what am I
doubting why am I doubting is there any
evidence to support that and then when
we get clear that hey I actually can do
this if I go get qualified if I go make
some connections now all of a sudden
we're not having to lie and here's the
big takeaway the reason we bring this up
is because you can do severe damage to
your ability to earn money
if you get caught lying like this yeah I
mean it because if you're lying on a
resume you'll lie on the job
and and that's the idea and if I'm the
hiring manager I'd rather you come to me
and say Hey listen I know you require
this much experience here's what I'm
bringing to the table I know I'm not
quite there but here's what I'm doing to
get there I'm impressed
you're ready to hire this guy right
versus someone lying to my face yeah
yeah not good come on be better George
Santos I'm trying to represent George's
out here you know Foreman Lopez Costanza
Washington I like that put respect on
our name you know what the problem is
the guy he's holding on for dear life
he's lied so much he doesn't even know
how to unravel or admit any of them I
don't even know if his name's George
anymore why we should look into that